ich habe mich eher amüsiert muss ich
sagen ich hab mich nicht aufgeregt ich
habe mich am sonntagabend amüsiert weil
da war friedrich merz zu sehen der im
bericht aus berlin
interviewt wurde und zwar zu seiner
rolle im sogenannten zukunftsteam von
armin laschet und da wurde er auch
gefragt wer denn die anderen sieben
seien in diesem zukunftsteam und der
konnte die namen nicht sagen also er hat
herumgedruckst er war erst war ein
bisschen erschrocken dass er das sagen
sollte dann darum gedruckt und hatte
sich entschlossen dem auszuweichen
wahrscheinlich hat er angestrengt
nachgedacht wie die wohl heißen und das
ist ihm nicht richtig ein gefallen und
jetzt albernes zeug da möchte ich nicht
drüber reden das ist noch zwei mal
nachgefragt worden und er hat die namen
nicht präsentiert ich glaube wenn man
sein gesicht gesehen hat weil es nicht
konnte und daraus lernen wir zwei dinge
erstens friedrich merz ist ein ziemlich
arrogant ab insel muss ich mal sagen er
hält es nicht für notwendig dass er die
namen von so
zweitklassigen leuten auswendig lernen
die dann mit ihm im team setzten
zweitens lernen wir dass in diesem tun
außer märz und peter neumann dem
erstklassigen wirklich erstklassig die
experten wirklich nur zwei klassische
leute sitzen und man sich die deren
namen nicht merken kann das haben wir
sozusagen in wenigen minuten als
fernsehzuschauer gesehen und da frage
ich mich was für ein vorteil eigentlich
armin laschet von der benennung dieser
truppe hat das ist die truppe der
namenlosen die er da aufgestellt hat er
kommt damit nicht voran wir können auch
nicht für ihn argumentieren ich habe
seither keinen außer märz gesehen die
irgendwo mal öffentlich aufgetreten sind
man will ja auch gar nicht sehen weil
man kennt sie ja auch gar nicht wofür
sind ja nicht zuständig was können sie
was haben sie geleistet
ziemlich schlechte aktion aus der panik
von laschet geboren im letzten moment
des wahlkampfs wird ihm glaube ich nicht
mehr helfen sondern im gegenteil eine
truppe der namenlosen hilft nichts
sondern zieht ihn weiter nach unten
könnte man sie denn auf sand ich kann
die nicht aufzählen ich kenne die auch
gar nicht die meisten kenne ich gar
nicht nur noch nie begegnet warum soll
ich die kultusministerin von
schleswig-holstein kennen mit der habe
ich nie was zu tun gehabt es keine
bundespolitikerin sie ist über
schleswig-holstein hinaus nicht in die
öffentlichkeit getreten wenn sie es gibt
man hat nicht so dass ich es hätte
bemerken müssen interessiert mich nicht
tut mir leid und ich frage mich was sie
in so einem team macht da muss ich sagen
was armin laschet angeht besser kein
team als so 1 sie erstmal die mutigste
bildungsministerium von deutschland per
bild gewesen dass das nicht registriert
wurde das ist ein minus ab und damit
öffentliche leben jetzt aber da war war
ich noch nicht hier weil ich
meine dass das problem ist eigentlich
ein anderes also ich hätte auch massiven
widerstand in mir wenn mich jemand
examinierten möchte das widerstrebt mir
einfach ich bin nicht in der situation
dass man jemand kommt nämlich ab fragt
da werden mache ich sofort zu also das
gibt es nicht wenn er insofern verstehe
ich märz dass er sagt
sorry aber ich bin da nicht derjenige
der geprüft wird aber wenn wenn das so
ist das dass deutschlands mutigste
kultusminister ist kann er doch sagen
pass mal auf über 1000 ps natürlich habe
ich wie sich schilder ihnen mal drei
jahr für acht erreicht uns die zeit
nicht die eine ist deutschlands mutigste
kultusministerin der zweite ist der
führende terrorexperte deutschlands die
dritte ist dies und jenes wird dorothea
hätte besser verschweigen sollen denn
das ist eine große peinlichkeit
aufkommen wir vielleicht noch die frau
die nichts an digitalisierung zustande
gebracht hat soll jetzt digitalisierung
voranbringen das sich längst schon
wieder verteidigen so einem team ist das
natürlich wirklich das allerletzte aber
vielleicht hört friedrich merz auch
nichts an piano oder die kelly family
die von dem manager dort vertreten
worden sind dass der musikmanager ja da
muss man aber wenn man so einer truppe
sitzt sie mal erkundigen was machen denn
die anderen eigentlich und woher kommen
die und was können die vielleicht liegt
es auch einfach an der wuchshöhe wenn
man ein friedrich merz ist mit 195
aussteller guckt man sehr stark von oben
herab und kann gar nichts dafür das ist
einer der größten nachteile den er in
dieser kampagne wahlkampagne immer
wieder zeigt dann ist heiko maas er
beugt sich nach vorne senkt den kopf und
dann sind die mundwinkel noch bis zur
tischkante und das gibt einen auf den
ersten anhieb unsympathisch werden denn
man ich habe das noch in erinnerung als
er mit hupac diskutiert hat und saß dem
gegenüber habe gab den ganz lässigen
ging zum wirtschaftspolitik und
eigentlich dachte man der märz musste im
himmel weit überlegen sein war aber
nicht sondern guckte nur grimmig über
die tischkante
aber ich frage mich dann also das ist ja
wirklich gnadenlos ihr urteil muss ich
schon sagen und bevor sie von anderen
fordern dass sie sich erkundigen sollen
erkundigen sie sich doch mal über frau
prien die frau hatten nahmen und die ist
sehr stark auch im einsatz
beispielsweise gegen antisemitismus und
das ist ja mitnichten so dass die leute
die bekannter sind die besseren sind sie
haben ja herrn merz gerade auch ein
vernichtendes urteil ausgesprochen und
das ist ja der bekannteste im interview
eingeladen oder über die truppe würde
ich mich als journalist sollte man das
vielleicht auch schon es geht ja gar
regierung gibt manche leute soziale
beispielsweise auch ein quereinsteiger
also die frage ist ja wir beschweren uns
immer über politik das alles so wie
immer ist dann bringt man neue leute
wird dafür auch gelöscht es war ein
falscher zeitpunkt gegebenenfalls also
das mag ich gar nicht bewerten wir haben
auch ein paar köpfe gefehlt wo es
linnemann wo sie einsparen wo es herab
kühler so meine persönliche meinung sage
ich mal aber das jetzt so kaputt zu
reden und so zu personalisieren finde
ich halt schwierig und trotzdem sagen
das
habe ich in der letzten sendung hier die
absolute nukleare these verbreitet dass
diese cdu gut das kommt einfach nicht
mehr gut ist in diesem raum sollen sich
in die opposition zurückziehen und dort
wieder gesunden dann habe ich einen
unglaublichen shitstorm geerntet aus
deutschland haben sie hatte vorkommen
verstand von nein das ist kann man
daran erkennen
dass deutlich rot-grün-rot ausliefern
und die sich sorgen seit ich diese mails
bekommen habe bete ich tatsächlich dafür
dass rot grün rot nicht gewinnen wird
weil wenn das passiert jetzt aus
schweizer sicht beurteilt man dann haben
wir einen massenexodus von allen
mittelständlern und leuten die ein
gewisses durchschnittseinkommen haben
aus deutschland weil das steuer in ein
irrenhaus
lilien preise weit nach oben gehen das
stimmt nein das hatte ich einen seriösen
charakter es ist natürlich schon für
europa
wahnsinnig wichtig dass dieses
deutschland jetzt einfach nicht seine
erfolgs prinzipien über bord wie zum
beispiel die soziale marktwirtschaft die
freiheit eigenverantwortung
unternehmertum wenn ich doch diesen
diskussionen zu hören dann habe ich den
eindruck es gibt nur noch über staat
umverteilung noch mehr gesetze und ich
glaube das ist das problem mit dieser
mit diesem team ich kann diese leute
dazu wenig beurteilen ob die gut oder
schlecht sind es wirkt etwas verzweifelt
ich hoffe einfach dass armin laschet
nach wie vor massiv unterschätzt wird
aber wenn ich in eure gesichter schaue
da und denke ich habe mich schon mitleid
konnte das ist doch der letzte der noch
irgendwie eine hoffnung auf rasche im
moment
bin ich finde ihn gut wäre wenn er einen
game changer machen müsste in diesem
wahlkampf fehler einer wirklichen game
changer machen müsste aber wenn ich das
sage dann wird mich fragte gleich aus
dem studio prügel sorgen okay nachdem
schulz gesagt hat ich spanne jetzt mit
der ex sed zusammen also mit der
linkspartei gesagt so habe das angebot
auch nicht angehört oder nicht ist damit
erschließen es erschließt nicht richtig
anheizen müsste jetzt müsste lautet um
das gleichgewicht des schreckens wieder
herzustellen müsste sagen okay wenn du
nach ganz links gehst dann sage ich dann
schließe ich auch ein bündnis mit der
fdp anhänger war ein sonnenbrand das
studio wie alt ich bekomme die us-armee
dieses und bekomme mit der tausende von
mails gesagt jetzt enkel johann
verschraubt von nashville ich wollte
darf ich noch ein zwei varianten dann
bin ich ja
wusste dass ich mir warum bringt es sich
um da bringt das historische leben schon
in dollar werden das sind halt die
schweizer volkspartei ist vielleicht
eine andere als die afg aber nach elf
jahren in der afg gibt es nun mal eine
ganze menge nazi ist da und mit denen
kann man rangliste dann eben diese fd
zivilisieren doch werde der australier
überhaupt niemand die wollen die
christen und wollen ja kassieren ich
wollte nur sagen wenn sie schon dem
scholz nicht trauen was die linke angeht
die grünen wären verrückt wenn sie mit
den linken koalieren da bin ich ganz
sicher weil die alle stimmen aus der
mitte diese gekriegt haben sofort wieder
verlieren werden da wären sie wieder bei
das große problem bei diesem team ist
doch dass armin laschet kein team wollte
er hat das ausdrücklich mehrfach gesagt
er wolle kein team weil es immer als
konkurrenz zum kabinett gesehen wird das
heißt man fragt sich jetzt natürlich
warum ist eigentlich überhaupt kein
minister aus dem kabinett dabei sind das
alles pfeifen
warum sind die hoffnungsträger der
partei nicht dabei um ein
landesvorsitzender kein minister wenn
man sich jetzt das team anguckt ist
irgendjemand dabei auf dem man richtig
gespannt ist man also ambra dass das ist
eine tolle sache das war vor jahren mit
dem verfassungsrechtler kirchhof war das
so eine sache der war irgendwie bekannt
für seine radikalen reformen thesen
gegen einfach nicht wirklich gut mir
dass das ging nicht gut das geht nicht
gut das ist immer das problem bei so
einem team wenn man so diese
strahlemänner hat die spd hat mal mit
jost stollmann versucht ich weiß nicht
ob das noch jemand erinnert und computer
unternehmer gegen alles baden weil in
der regel fachleute nicht wirklich für
die politik fähig sind aber jetzt auf
den letzten rang wieder willen so ein
team aufzustellen nach dem eigentlich
keiner gefragt hat ist einfach ein
risiko
[Musik]